-Our next guest represents
California's 28th
Congressional district.
His number one "New York Times"
best selling book
"Midnight in Washington:"
How We Almost Lost Our Democracy
and Still Could"
is on sale now.
Please welcome back to the show
Congressman Adam Schiff.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
How are you?
-I'm good. I'm good.
-This is a lovely place to
see you.
The last time I saw you
was not where I expected
to see a congressman.
I was at my inlaws' house.
-Yes.
-I was sitting on the steps
with my son.
-And I was lost.
-Yeah.
-And I drove up to a house
with my cousin and knocked on
the door. And it was you.
-Yeah.
-And then I was even more lost.
-Yeah, and your cousin
stepped out of the car.
And I was trying to help him
and give him directions.
And we had met.
And you stepped out.
And I will admit based on the
role you often serve
in government I thought I was
about to get served a subpoena.
[ Laughter ]
Because in movies
they always trick you.
Always start talking about
something else
and then they hand it to you.
And I'm like, son of a gun.
-Now that you mention it --
-Oh, no, no, no.
-So you're very honest about
a lot of things in this book.
Including how you feel about
some of your colleagues.
Including Kevin McCarthy
who we talked about earlier
in the show.
How do you feel -- I should --
I should point out,
maybe not the biggest fan
of Kevin McCarthy.
And how did you feel watching
his eight and a half hour
speech the other night.
-It was torture.
-Yeah.
-It was my first moron-a-thon.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
And I kept thinking if this is
his way of punishing Paul Gosar
why make the rest of us suffer.
-Right have to sit through it.
-It was rambling,
it was incoherent.
And the strange thing
about it is,
if you're going to filibuster
something, do you really want to
filibuster early childhood
education, quality child care,
hearing aids for seniors?
The most vigorous effort to
combat climate change?
Is that really what you want to
try to filibuster?
-Well, I wonder why it
is he would do that.
Because Build Back Better,
the elements of it,
are very popular,
these are things people want.
And yet the Republican Party
does seem like there is
some sort of electoral advantage
to running against it.
Do you feel like
people are going to
get excited about this bill?
And do you feel like
it's something
the Democratic Party is going to
be able to run on
as they approach the mid-terms
and, maybe,
people are not particularly
optimistic about
insofar as how your party's
going to do.
-I think we're going to have
the most comprehensive
positive agenda any Congress
had to run on.
The combination of
the rescue plan,
the infrastructure bill,
Build Back Better,
will be, essentially, the new
deal for this new generation,
lifting half the nation's
children out of poverty,
attacking the problem
of climate change,
helping all Americans with
prescription drug prices,
helping young people
afford college,
helping others get a good job.
And, you know,
the challenge will be,
okay, what are we going to focus
on when we go around the country
and tell people what we did
because it's so expansive?
But I think it gives us a
real fighting chance to buck
that mid-term trend,
where the party in power
in the White House loses seats.
And we are going to have to
defeat that trend.
Because the idea that someone
with the kind of lack
of morality or ethics
like Kevin McCarthy
could ever go near the Speaker's
office is just terrifying.
-You know, I don't know
the history of the new deal.
I obviously know how it was
received once it was passed.
But how much do you think
what's being passed now
is suffering from how fraught
the negotiations have been
sort of within
the Democratic Party?
Because it does feel like every
part of it is just being
dragged across the finish line.
And, you know because
of the cable news cycle
and talking about how difficult
it is to get it passed
I think people may think there's
something wrong to it.
-I think
the lead up to the passage
of the infrastructure bill,
you know,
had Democrats
fighting Democrats.
And that was just
singly destructive.
When we got to the Build Back
Better there was none of that.
I think we realized just we
can't afford to be fighting
amongst ourselves.
You know, the answer to the
challenge of getting more
out of the Senate is we need
more Democrats in the Senate.
We need to -- if we can't get
everything we want
with an evenly divided Senate
that's 50/50,
we need more Democrats in
the Senate to be able to
build on
what we've already done.
It's not to go after each other.
-So you were the first
impeachment manager.
Now there's the January 6th
investigation.
We're going to come up,
you know --
obviously we're going to come up
on the year anniversary
pretty soon.
What is -- what are you hopeful
to accomplish from this?
Because one thing
that makes me depressed
is it doesn't seem like
anyone involved in that
has paid any price at all.
And it's doubtful based on how
polling is going right now
for Republicans,
that it is going to ever
have a cost for them.
Is that -- is there any outcome
here where people
don't look at what you find
and it's just a partisan result,
like some people and go, "Oh,
that's what I always expected."
Or other people look at it and
say, "This is a witch hunt?"
-Look, I think all we can do
is expose all the malefactors,
follow the evidence
wherever it leads,
tell the American people
the story of
what went in to January 6th, all
the planning that went into it,
who was behind it
in terms of the money.
What Donald Trump was doing,
what he was not doing
at the time that the Capitol
was being attacked.
And make the case publicly,
expose all the wrong doing,
and at the same time
make sure that we
don't lose sight of our
legislative agenda.
And we have to hope that there
is still enough American people
with an open mind that they will
follow the hearings
that we're going to have
in public,
that they'll be interested in
what we conclude.
We are working in a very
non-partisan way,
Democrats and Republicans
on the subcommittee.
It's one of the few bright spots
in the Congress right now.
But I think
what you're pointing to is
one of the overarching
challenges we have
which is people don't get all
their information
from the same places.
Of all the Facebook
whistle-blower allegations
that I found the most troubling
was at Facebook they created
a Republican woman.
They gave her only a few
attributes.
She was "Fox" viewing, she was
Christian, and Republican.
And their algorithms led her
straight to QAnon.
And as long as that's the case
and people are led down
these tragic conspiratorial
rabbit holes
we're going to have this
horrible divide.
So we're going to have to try to
address that challenge.
-Steve Bannon who seems to
commit a lot of crimes
but not get any better at it
while he goes,
he was sort of called
in front of the house,
basically wouldn't
turn over documents.
Correct me
if I get any of this wrong.
And now he has been arrested.
Do you think this is going to
end up with him -- I don't know,
like, being cooperative
with the committee to
try to stay out of prison?
Or do you think he will continue
to be sort of stuck in his ways?
-I don't know. And, Seth,
I look at one thing
as sort of a microcosm,
just shows you what a consummate
group of grifters were running
the country.
A man runs for President on a
platform of building a wall
that he says Mexico
is going to pay for.
-I don't think he said that, no.
-Of course.
He becomes President.
He doesn't build a wall.
Mexico doesn't pay for it.
-Right.
-His cronies then start a fund
raising money
from his own supporters to
purportedly build a wall.
They steal it.
Like Steve Bannon.
They are indicted for stealing
money from his own people.
And then he pardons them.
And they're just a bunch
of crooks and grifters.
But you can understand
why Steve Bannon believed
that he was above the law,
because for four years he was.
But now we have a justice
department that believes
no one is above the law.
And I think the effect of this
prosecution, whatever he does,
has already had a very important
impact on other witnesses
who have decided to cooperate
because they don't want to
be prosecuted like Steve Bannon.
-There's -- you talk about
January 6th and your colleagues
from across the aisle were
concerned about your wellbeing.
Like that was a very harrowing
day in real time, I think,
that when something like that
happens,
people do fall back to their
best humanity, right?
Concern about people they maybe
don't agree with all the time.
Has is it been depressing to you
that that moment of,
maybe, seeing the best in people
you don't agree with
has faded away?
-It is. I was there, as you
know, for the 6th.
And as they were breaking
the doors and windows to get in,
I had a number of Republicans
come up to me and say,
"You can't let them see you."
One of them said,
"I know these people.
I can talk to these people.
I can talk my way
through these people,
you can't let them see you."
You're in
a whole different category.
And I was -- you know, I was
touched that they were concerned
about my safety.
But immediately that thought was
followed by another,
that if they hadn't been lying
about the election,
I wouldn't need to be
worried about my safety.
And none of us would.
And when we left the chamber
and came back
after the police put down
that insurrection
these same people
were pushing --
still pushing the big lie.
Still voting to overturn
the election.
And whatever good will
I felt about their concern
for me evaporated.
We had a chance
after that terrible tragedy
to turn a corner as a country.
But they have just -- these --
What I call insurrectionists
in suits and ties have just
doubled down on the big lie.
And they're persuading millions
of Americans
that we can't trust
our elections.
And if you persuade
millions of people
that we can't trust our
elections to decide
who should govern,
then what is left but violence?
And this is -- this is why
things are so precarious.
But the answer has to be
not despair.
The answer has to be engagement,
even greater engagement
to get us through this.
One of the reasons I titled the
book "Midnight in Washington"
is midnight is the darkest hour
of every day.
But it's also a hopeful time.
Because we know that what
follows is light.
And there are millions and
millions more Americans
who love and cherish our
democracy
than those who are determined at
the moment to tear it down.
And they will
get us through this.
-Well, I'm just going to
say this.
It sounds like a really weird
place to work.
Thank you so much.
That's Congressman Adam Schiff,
everybody.
"Midnight in Washington"
is out now.